- I'm terrified.
- I'm looking to really
learn what it's all about.
This is kinda all I know.
- We are introducing
Bollywood dance to Americans
who have never experienced
Bollywood before.
- I want all off the face,
tons and tons of energy and drama.
I don't care about anything else.
Even if you've never one this before,
I don't want to see it on your face.
I want your face to be like...
I got this, the whole time, okay?
So I expect people to come in
with a fair amount of trepidation.
Usually people are a little
bit nervous to try it
because it looks so dramatic
and big and exciting,
and sometimes cheesy.
As soon as we jump into it, I think
with me screaming and yelling at them,
they'll forget all about
it and just be able to
jump in and learn the moves.
Good, so that's your basic
and that's your step-touches.
Thumb, index, middle, ring, pinky.
- It was so many emotions.
It was like, sexy face,
happy face, sexy face,
serious, sexy, happy,
sexy, happy, it was--
- But overall sexy angry,
like sexy goes before
every other adjective.
- Okay, so now we're
going to have my dancers,
my beautiful professional dancers come out
in their costumes, and we're going to show
the new dancers exactly what the combo's
supposed to look like with costumes.
(upbeat Indian music)
(cheering)
- So are you ready to do it like that?
Let's get you in your costumes,
put some bindis on you,
get some ankle bells on the
girls, some kurtas on the boys.
Come on, let's go!
- [Man] It's a different
type of exercise, I think.
- [Woman] It's just fun.
For anyone who thinks they
can't dance, just do Bollywood.
It's just bouncing and just fun.
- [blond woman] A lot of this.
- [woman in glasses] Yeah.
- A lot of this.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] It was so much fun!
- [Voiceover] It was a blast!
I had so much fun, oh my God.
- [Voiceover] I think it takes
a different type of control.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I'm
taking this to the club
Friday night and see how I fare.
- [blond woman] It was intense, though.
- I feel like, even if you
don't really get the movements,
as long as you have the
energy and you're just
bouncing all over the place--
- Yeah.
- You'll get by.
- [blond woman] You know.
I feel like we could maybe be
in the background of some Bollywood movie.
- [woman in glasses] Exactly.
- [blond woman] And just do
this and be like, yeah,
we do this for a living.